قد يعود الانسان من سفر طويل او غياب لم
يكن محدد وقت انتهائه لكن العوده من الموت
هي الامر الاكثر غرابه حادثه غريبه صدمت
الشريعه المصريه وقعت تفاصيلها في قريه
قرب المنوفيه في مصر تلخصت بعوده ميت بعد
دفنه بشهر تفاصيل القصه وقعت حين دفنت
عائله مصريه فقيده المدعو محمد عادل الذي
افترض انه توفي بحادث سياره وتم دفن جثته
بعد السلامها لكن محمد عاد بعد شهر من
الدفن والعزاء ليصدم عائلته وجيرانه الذين
لم يصدقوا الامر في بدايته ليكون السؤال
الاهم عندهم من هو المدفونه سؤال تحقق
السلطات المصريه حاليا لمعرفه هويه الجثه
المدفونه
[موسيقى]
اولا محمد عادل انا فوجئت بوالدتي وانا
نازل رايح المدرسه الصبح طالع رحله شغلي
والدتي ومرات اخويا قاعدين بره قدام البيت
بيعيطوا في اي حاجه بتعيطي ليه ايه
الموضوع في ايه قالت لي محمد ابن اخوك امه
بتقول بقى له ثلاث ايام مش موجود وفعلا
الولد بقى له ثلاث ايام مش موجود طب مش
موجود راح فين امه قالت ده كان بيقول انا
هاروح شغل خد بعض ومشى مشى امتى يا ست
الكل قالت لي مشي بالليل طب ماشي بالليل
راح فين المهم طبعا بدات اسال على محمد
واشوف محمد موجود فين فبدات
او الناس اللي بيقعد وياها او الاماكن
اللي بتردد فيها فبدات الناس تعرف ان محمد
متغير محمد ابن اخويا متغير
بدت الناس تدور معي في اللي يقول لي انا
شايفه في القناطر الخيريه
بيمسي عربيات اللي يقول لي انا شايفه على
الدائري او تحت الدائري عند بشوش تحت
الكوبري اللي يقول احنا شايفينه في
القليوبيه اللي انا شايفينه على محطه
القطار اي مكان كان يتقل علينا محمد موجود
فيه كنت بروحه قال لي اتصل تليفون في يوم
من الايام يوم الخميس من بلد من شاب من
جنبنا احنا من قريه
ولا اثنين شمال
ابنكم موجود في محطه وردان في محطه وردان
او اقل حتى زي كده محطه قطر ففي واحد من
الناس اللي واقفه قال انا شفت الولد ده
منشور على النت قالوا بيدوروا عليه الكلام
ده كان يوم خميس يوم الاحد الصبح الساعه
6:00 الا ربع
نفس الشخص اتصل علي قال يا استاذ علي ابنك
اللي انتم بتدوروا عليه موجود في مستشفى
مبارك بالمناشي في العنايه المركزه اخذنا
بعض
ظرف مش هينفع اخذنا بعضنا ورحنا كلنا كسره
دخلنا المستشفى يا جماعه انتم عندكم احد
هنا عامل حادثه حادثه القطار حادثه القطار
قال اه ده فاقد الاهليه وموجود بقى له خمس
ايام في العنايه المركزه مسكنا الوقت
فحصناه ما احنا برده عايزين نتاكد اننا
ولا مش ابننا ماشي لقينا الولد هو محمد
فضلنا نعالج فيه
حبنا ننقله مستشفى خاصه وننقلوا بره مدير
المستشفى قال لي يا استاذ علي ابنكم مش
هينفع الاثنين او يتحرك من مكانه الحاله
خطيره كملنا نبات العلاج
يوم الجمعه يوم الجمعه يوم 14 10
وادي صلاه الجمعه
الى ربنا سبحانه وتعالى خلصنا الاجراءات
وجبنا بعضنا وجينا
وجبنا وجئنا على الساعه 8:30 بالليل 8:30
بالليل يوم الجمعه يوم 14 10 ماشي
بقى خلصنا الكلام انا باقول لهم هتفضحونا
انت بتتكلموا في ايه الناس هتطلع هنا كلام
في المكان ده ونزل منها خمس ست شباب ومحمد
عادل نازل لي صلاه النبي في شنطه بلاستيك
في ايده انا فكرت انقسم بتاعه
وطالع وتطلع ازاي بعد 27 يوم وقال لي منين
محمد عادل طب هل دي محمد عادل
فوجئت طبعا بسياده المامون مركز اشمون
بيتصل علي ما كملناش ما فيش سياده المامور
بيتصل علي يا محمد بيه ابو العزم
استاذ علي قلت له يا فندم معك الاستاذ
اللي عندك قلت له يا فندم حصل كذا كذا كذا
اللي انا وقفت في علاجه انا واهلي
اخذنا التحويشه بتاع موسى
يا ابني ان انت مش محمد عادل انا مين
انا مخلف ولا مش مخلف معي ايه
ما انا مش عارف هو مين
[موسيقى]